this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised this is why the inclement ride
is such a firm favorite it's Quito
[Music]
it just looks ready for a fight
[Music]
this is still her territory how insane
was that well good afternoon everybody
and welcome to our 18th installment of
Safari lives it promises to be an epic
epic epic afternoon we've had lots and
lots of signs of animals during the
course of the day and we even have an
elephant herd back on the property which
is very very nice now of course we're
not going to be focusing too much on
these it's all about our cat characters
or all of our characters actually over
the course of the next two hours and so
hopefully you going to sit back grab
whatever drink you like to drink whether
it be a tea coffee or something else and
enjoy the next two hours my name is
Justin on camera I've got Sebastian this
afternoon and hopefully you're going to
like I say enjoy what's going to go and
remember that you can interact with us
hashtag Safari live on Twitter also at
FC on the YouTube chat if you would like
to ask questions remember to keep them
relevant to what you're seeing on screen
and we'll try and answer as many as
possible now it's nice to see some
Ellie's around the reason why we
actually here with the Ellie's is
because we're trying to find her sana at
the moment husana was around this area
this morning and so we bumped into these
guys on our way to try and kind of have
a look for him and so nice to see like I
said we haven't really seen too many
Eddie's around at all now this week has
been a very very very good week for us
here at Safari live we've had many many
many many sightings including all of
them pretty much all of our characters
and it's been one of those weeks where
things have happened we've also had a
bit of rain so lots of changes around
and I wonder if that means we're going
to continue to see some epic sightings
when it comes to all of the animals that
move around in this area hopefully it
will be hopefully it's going to continue
from today and we'll carry on having a
really really kind of good time of it
sees a little baby Ellie there looks
like a smallish Amy walking around in
the background there's quite a few here
it's a nice-sized heard that we've
actually got at this stage right
I think we need to actually just
reposition ourselves a little bit
because it's not going to get much
better in terms of the view lots of
bushes in the way and the road is
actually just on the other side so while
we try and find our way around and see
if we can get a slightly better visual I
was saying that's been a good week and
lots and lots of cats have been around
so why don't you take a look at where
they've all been moving it was a busy
week on Juma as most of our cat
characters made an appearance we started
the week with a bang as a single Impala
provided food form for Kazi ting Ghana
and husana from the kill both Dingaan
and hasanah headed north
Isana made a brief appearance at the
damn camp before heading towards buffers
of dam from the dam that apple prince
marched his race up off in search of a
meal and eventually found what he was
looking for as he stolen in particle
from shadaloo meanwhile 10 Ghana was
once again found at the same kiln for
Kazi had been seen on the investing pack
made a brief incursion into the west of
the reserve Inca Houmas also returned
just north of the camp to round out the
week we finally found Tandy and Columba
as they made their way through the
southeast to a stash dykey hill up in
the Mara waffles and Cubs were in their
usual spot at the den Kapali was also
found in the south of the triangle while
his pride the sausage free pride and
kinky tail followed the wildebeest to
the west up in the far north the playful
paradise pride spent the afternoon close
to the river well as you can see been a
busy week both here and in the Maasai
Mara lots and lots of movement between
all of our cats and some surprises in
the form of folk Ozzy and that unknown
male lipid so lots kind of been around
and it's going to be interesting to see
whether or not the change in weather and
as we start heading into our summer
months and rain starts to fall whether
that's going to influence how things go
and whether we going to see the same
amount of movement of our cats is
definitely been a lot more shifting
around particularly by hasana
he's covering a lot more ground these
days than he has over the last few
months he's been spent most of his time
in central parts of human but you can
see now that he's starting to expand
outwards and is moving all kinds of
directions as he goes along but he's in
the school does the Seas amalias I know
we trying to find our cats more than
anything else but
like I said it's just been so kind of
dry with Elias of late here in Juma that
it's fantastic to actually see them back
in this area you can see that females
just dusting that so she gets rid of all
the soil before she starts to eat the
roots at this stage of the year there
really is very little for these guys to
actually feed on and so they need to be
able to eat something and what roots and
tubers are going to be the best thing
for them to get eat now this early is
going to be approaching us fairly
closely and so while we later come past
in silence
let's send you across to the Taylor
mccurdy so she can say good afternoon to
all of you good afternoon everyone from
again just welcome to Safari knives we
were hopefully going to find lots and
lots of cats and we're basically hitted
now to where we left
Tandi this morning on Sunrise Safari so
unfortunately Sandi gave us the
runaround she diversity drainage lands
which she typically likes to do now if
you've only just perhaps started
watching a safari lab and you are very
uncertain as to who some of these
animals are that we're talking about
said to animals we're talking about not
people so tündi is a female leopard who
lives around and in this area she's
taken over her mother's sort of home and
fortune here her mom Karuna is not
around anymore
so only fitting and as it normally
happens with leopards she's now moved
into this big space that's available and
its prime property so she's been
exploring quite a bit she's also got a
daughter her name is Columbo we might
meet up with her a little bit later so
she stashed young Columba in a drainage
line and tree or somewhere around not
that clever really stays in one place in
these days and she's kinda you ain't on
walkabout looking for things to eat
cheese spotted some in Jana which was
great but she didn't make an attempt on
them she left it a little bit too long
or maybe she thought she didn't really
have a good enough chance so that kind
of all happened this morning so we're
gonna head back into that area to try
and find her but she was in the middle
of two drainage lines which was between
two different roads so I think we'll
just check the surrounding area first
check
sandy places to see if she walked in
that area and that's that's sort of how
we're gonna start it off and hopefully
it will all pay off but it is a tough
game trying to relocate on animals and
lots of concentration will be needed so
we're gonna go and do some tracking
something you can't do in the Mara
Triangle welcome good afternoon
caribou sana - the Mara triangle in
Kenya where the temperatures are very
nice 26 degrees Celsius 81 degrees
Fahrenheit and we are with the North
clan surrounded by an enormous herd of
zebra and wildebeest they are lying up
in what is a nice cool afternoon with
some clouds and rain in the distance
welcome my name is Steve I'm joined by
big James on camera and we're out in the
African wilderness we thought would pay
a little visit to these individuals and
North Claire and lying up here in the
open we with them a little bit early in
this week when they Cubs the little ones
were not quite as shy as they are right
now
my first visits of North plan then
heralded a wonderful society and waffles
and her two young cubs both showing off
the early spotted coats of budding
adolescence Elsa be resource in
attendance and under hers and waffles
watchful eye the enthusiastic and
inquisitive youngsters have ventured out
what's initially looked like played was
actually practice of the important
social norms and techniques that will
undoubtedly become commonplace for these
two in the daily life of being a Klan
member but for now our play is play and
these two youngsters don't have to worry
too much about all that and running
around is a great way to stretch muscles
and then off any buds up energy hmm how
interesting is it to find the little
youngsters running around and performing
the the arts of being an adult but it's
not too serious at these stages we
arrived about half an hour ago and there
was no one in attendance and with all
the bearson's ever feeding around the
den itself and one by one first one to
our back was waffles and as soon as she
did she's the one there with a her
bottom in the hall more soon as she
arrived back three little youngsters
popped their head out of little holes in
the ground and then one by one these are
the individual Lane had joined back and
we're very fortunate enough to see the
little ones come out and this youngster
in the front of the screen on the
bottom-right actually was doing a little
bit of sort of that characteristic side
on greeting ceremony with all of the
youngsters one at a time and I'm pretty
sure at the moment two of the youngsters
are busy suckling a little hole in the
ground that they pop out of and that
possibly could be one of the other pups
a believable Cubs I believe get fuzzy
and isof also got one each and waffles
has got two all about the same age I
can't tell the difference I've only seen
three and the last two times we were
here we only saw two
and on our rivals a little while ago
three of them were up and about and
moving all over the place but two of
them clearly more interested in waffles
than the other one lying on her head and
competing with each other for Mother's
Milk which is always very interesting
and one individual Heine that's at the
back now came all the way forward but
was chased off not very well-liked near
and around the axis which is quite
interesting to watch that idem because
they are all all related in all part of
the same family but she's not allowed
nearby I wonder wonder what that could
be
are we gonna spend some time here and
see if the little youngsters come out
maybe you can have a look at that one
there the back James
she oh she's put a hit down again she
keeps looking over yet he's very
interested very interested in what's
going on over here but it's not really
loud
Zachery the weather today is fantastic
it was a bit hot in classic African
style Ezreal even Kemp James was saying
oh it's very hot and the guys of the
gate also saying very very hot but that
has led to some thunderstorms and rain
in the distance and the wind has picked
up and the clouds have pulled in and it
is actually really nice and cool at the
moment now this morning was nice and
warm and this afternoon is promised for
some cooling down all of the Valle de
beast and there are so many of them
accumulating in and around the river at
the moment every single patch of shade
on our way through had a huge group of
all the beasts and crammed underneath
trying to sort of keep out of the midday
Sun but I don't think many of these
animals really understand what a hot day
is like I should come down to South
Africa for a little bit and see exactly
how our summers get a 30 odd degree
Celsius up here they feel a little bit
warm even the zebra was standing in the
shade when in South Africa zebra in the
heat of the day 40 degrees Celsius is
about 110 Fahrenheit standing in the
full sunshine completely not bothered at
all there you can see one of the little
youngsters two of them starting to pop
out of the hole but while we see if we
can get them out a little bit more let's
go all the way back down to South Africa
with Taylor mccurdy
well we haven't really found anything
just did except they're all going to go
in the bushes it see if one will come
out we've got a small family of kudu
just moving through this quarry thicket
it might actually be heading down to the
pan for a bit of a drink well these are
great animals it's just sort of to watch
and also to know their position and I
always talk about this because now we've
got two potential efforts that could be
in this area
Tristan's looking for husana around here
and I'm looking for Tandy and if we hear
any big kudu barks
although I'm sure there's quite a few
could you out at the moment they sound
like they're around for your tiller damn
would probably be this lot and they are
exceptionally vigilant they've got big
ears of a very good eyesight so they do
tend to spot the big cats
that'll be trying to hunt them although
I think Tony would prefer to go for
something a little bit smaller but
whoreson on the other hand well he
wouldn't have any problems bringing down
one of those younger kudu like that
young male but there are slowly making
their way down towards the pan so I
think I'll just do it basically just do
a little bit of a quick loop and if we
don't find anything I think we head all
the way down to the southern corner of
the reserve and see if we can find a
male lion that was lingering around
there today go rockets carry on let's go
see if we can find attendee but Tristan
actually spent the most time with
attendee this week and let's go see if
they found themselves a meal or two
after weeks of searching we finally
catch up with both Tandy and Columba and
they have a kill Tanith if a disgrace
and experience voiced so vital million
to a beautiful ability
the llama is not far behind and soon
joins her mother after tree even though
it takes her slightly longer
once up she grabbed the carcass at once
trying to reposition it she twists and
turns the cart is closely watched by her
mother's Stern gaze eventually after a
good feed the folks llama join her mom
back on the ground the two then United
in a grooming session as the others fell
the next morning returned to fine sandy
having a breakfast she had a few
mouthfuls before returning to the ground
as soon as she landed the total amber
like a shot climb the tree with a stay
like her mother's she surveyed the
surrounding terrain
well that was epic that they did get a
meal it was really entertaining to watch
salamba as she's learning it to move the
carcass around and unlike that she was
trying to stash the carcass in some of
the holes in that apple leaf tree right
but another surprise for you is just
down to the waste of us Tristan has
finally managed to find her sana sans
indeed we have we found exactly who we
were looking for so we found little
husana who's not so little these days
with his big full tummy and big pores
and he is having a serious nap he is a
tired voice obviously been moving around
quite a bit during the course of the day
and so he's seems as though he's a
little kind of sleepy and tired in the
shade at the moment and look at the size
of his front paw even in relation to his
head and shoulders you can see that
there's some bulk in that's in some
serious size starting to come through on
husana he's he's amazing actually um
he's kind of developing I actually
looked at him this morning for the first
time in a while and thought to myself
well he stopped looking like a cub nah
he's really is looking like a solid male
leopard so got a young face but his body
is starting to really fill out quite a
lot and he's starting to look quite
thick-set much like what his dad often
looks like when they fall I know it's
when lipids are full they often look
better but just his chest and shoulders
area it was really starting to grow
quite a bit and it's really good that
we're seeing him kind of developing the
way he is I just hope that he's going to
be able to hang on into this area and
stay here
just be so wonderful to follow him can
you imagine following husana from when
he was born all the way through until he
becomes an old male lipid wouldn't that
just be the most wonderful thing I think
it would be awesome and so I'm hoping
that that's gonna be the case he's
probably got no better situation to do
that they need as at the moment they
don't think you could have wished for a
better kind of way things to have played
out with tin gana being their age that
he is and the condition that he's in at
the moment it should allow and buy time
for husana
to get big enough to be able to actually
kind of dominate and maybe even stick
around in this area QT kind of when we
first arrived yet a little open his eyes
is like thank goodness you guys are here
I've been waiting for you all day long
and had a little stretch and then
promptly went back to sleep easy he
knows that he's just got to kind of hold
out for a bit and then he'll start
oh my goodness sorry about that
everybody
that's no good now that's me Tristan
will be out and running soon enough okay
so he's still bumbling I haven't seen
any footprints coming out this way so I
don't know where well no not I don't
know that just eliminates that Tandy has
actually moved in this direction so this
is the antelope that Sonny was trying to
hunt this morning not this exact group
but a similar composition in fact there
were a few cows there was definitely one
big ball tailing the family group and
there were a couple of sub adults and
they seemed to be it's two youngsters
here as well well it was at least one
young young bull just feeding and again
just like the could you we've seen them
scattered all along these drainage lines
which is exactly where the leopards are
wanting to hunt that's where the food is
so better be careful no I haven't seen
any vultures or anything's perched up in
trees I haven't heard any alarm call
since we last saw one another it's been
still fairly quiet and I'm hoping that
if I just go around and just take it
before cut line that'll maybe see some
tracks of Tandy and then I've done about
hoping that they did get something to
eat so he could do with a meal she only
had a day care which kept their belly
full for a little but not for
particularly long and they slowly move
off and away back down to the drainage
line the wind is now starting to pick up
so tiny he could have taken a break
after he saw her this morning when she
eventually just disappeared behind a
termite mound and maybe you're just
saving her strength for a little bit
later it was very still it was beautiful
weather throughout the whole day but
this works better for the Predators in
terms of hunting
goodness his lots of little flies and
things around today
well I'll just have a little check
around here and then if there's nothing
we're gonna head down south and try our
like that side I know that Tristan see
it's something about the ink of rumor
pride being on chitwan I'm not sure if
they just but if it was that just that
they passed through if they're actually
there so well maybe also make our way
down that side and then go and do a bit
of investigating Chitra damn is always
nice and a good source of water our
chances of seeing some animals down
there will be fairly good as well okay
here's a nice sandy spot just to check
lots of elephant activity around today
it was even a few sleeping just outside
our rooms under a shady tree
hold on Craig
okay this is good news so it's and these
tracks have just picked up now from this
morning have come from some booty dance
so that means psy lumber is that side
we're gonna do a little bit more of
investigating within this area and
hopefully I'll have some positive news
for you later
Thank You Taylor well we have not got
any tracks we've got the animals which
is very cool and every now and again the
little youngster one of them pops Ted
out of that hole very cute very
interested in the big wide world and
we're hoping they'll come out at some
stage now that the adults are in
attendance it should be Tom the
youngsters to come out and play but I
think what's going on is the youngsters
or suckling the mum was away there we go
just in the whole bar waffles his head
there's a little one it's great to come
out it's just behind her there might
still be suckling you can actually see
below waffles as chin well in front of
her nose as a set of years and then
below her chin there's two little pause
there and that is one youngster with its
head down the borough feed it out and
saclink and you just see that little
pause and there's another one's face and
it's just coming out getting a little
bit inquisitive maybe wants to come and
say hello and this is ruffles the
matriarch wearing a collar for research
purposes people from the Michigan
University in the USA they're
researching them here
James Richard well I've only seen three
but apparently this should be for the
really small youngsters about that sort
of size and then I saw another sort of
medium sized to one a moment to go but I
think there's two of them so there's two
of them and then four of the really
small little little dark ones one with
ice one with fuzzy fuzzy bear thing and
then two with waffles the names are just
going to take me a very long time to
wrap my head around but here we go
he's gonna come out no still wants to
suckle look at those little feet just
under waffles his chin the cutest little
paws he see them there under shoulder
they're going to see the ear poking out
above her leg right down there by the
memory glands harush knee all four of
the really small ones all look very much
the same age I believe they are pretty
much the same age I can tell the
difference between them but I've only
seen three but they weren't together two
were with waffles by the hole and one
was popping its head out of the little
one hole on the side so I didn't see the
comparison of the three but Brent
assures me that they're pretty much the
same age and then the other one I saw
was pretty much already got the adult
sort of coloring with the spots and the
coloration but was still pretty small
slit pretty small little youngster for
five months or so it's the foot again
you can see the feeds it's upside down
there we go you look between waffles his
legs you can actually see the little
youngster busy suckling such a good
mother while the one youngster was
suckling the other one was lying on top
of waffles his head while she was lying
on the floor she was lying like that and
was like on top of the head not bothered
at all such a good mum so tolerant I
suppose until the youngsters start
biting things they shouldn't be my ting
they'll be their tolerated and at some
stage discipline or have to start coming
through
I landscape it but at the moment it is
the zoom we arrived at the murderous
Maura River just in time to watch a
large herd of zebra start to crash their
way through the dangerous waters the
first to go thrashed at the waters and
attracted the tension of logic the zebra
came ominously close to the waiting
predators once a Berlitz
are slits from the rest fell victim to a
very large croc the crocodile clamped
down as powerful jaws and pulled the
stricken zebra downstream with the rest
of the crocodiles quickly closed in this
moment allowed some zebra the freedom to
cross the river and challenged while
others shaken had seen one of their own
taken decided against taking the plunge
and turned back well I'm terribly sorry
about whatever technical issues happen
there if the link through to the zebra
crossing but how incredible was that to
be able to witness those individuals
crossing from the Maasai Mara side to
the triangle sided one per individual
falling victim to very large crocodile
and falling victim that turned out to be
36 very large crocodiles that just
completely dismembered that zebra in a
matter of about five minutes it was
drowned pretty quickly and then with a
very characteristic barrel rolls that
the crocodiles do well one out of a
million or 600,000 one out of the
600,000 fell victim to the crocodiles
which is all part and parcel of what
happens this time of year if you look
over the plains there a few Valle de
beers and few zebra from time to time
really do not dent what we can see
Archer is just thousands of thousands of
animals today I think I've seen more
Valda beast and zebra than I have seen
over the last few days and they all seem
to be moving closer and closer to the
river so the next few days James and I
are most certainly going to be spending
time closer to the river check in the
crossings a small
we nearly had one we actually had a very
small crossing of about seven zebra and
the crocodiles were not bothered at all
I think they weren't sort of excited by
the threat by the thrashing of the water
never too late the largest crocodiles
recorded are five and a half metres and
weighing over a thousand kilograms so
2,000 pounds and that's about what about
18 18 feet so that's enormous that is
very very big that was a crocodile that
was pulled out of the lava river in the
northern crew gap but I have no doubt
that there aren't possibly even bigger
crocodiles out there but that is what
the history books tell us and James just
inquisitive one keeps popping its head
in and out of that little hole there
he's too cute maybe he's waiting for mum
as well to come and suckle because
possibly getting quite hungry but anyway
the plains are bounding with animals and
we're going to move off shortly to go
and see if we can maybe find some lions
following these herds Lulu know that the
adults will possibly look after the den
but they won't suckle so from a
babysitting point of view yes most
certainly they will look after in God at
the end sight but they won't do any
communal suckling that is completely
reserved for the adults on its own
whereas in browner henan strata Nina
there's a lot of cross suckling it goes
to show how well linked and related
those families are but in Krakatoa
ricotta which is the spotted hyena
there's absolutely no assistance in the
milking of the youngsters and they do go
for a very long time almost a year of
providing milk and a lot of that's got
to do linked with the diet of numerous
amounts of bone that the higher almost
sort of unparallel in this environment
for accumulating or for for accessing
even once all the herds are gone the
hyena will be able to follow up on bones
and carcasses that had been left to
dotted around the plans and also when
they do catch an animal able to access
far more of it in the others do
but they were away I think maybe it's
because the herds surrounded the den
they're probably just moved off a few
meters into the shade and then as it
cooled down they came all the way back
again so anyway back down to South
Africa and hopefully Taylor mccurdy can
do something with those tracks so we're
just about to arrive at a buckles hook
dam which is slowly drying up but it's
one of the few downs that has a decent
amount of water in it so struck to have
a quick little look and see if anything
has come down to have a drink although
at first glance it kind of looks empty
a couple of birds Oh
hippos you know and why they're coming
this way
looks like they like making an escape
out of the water they're gonna come
straight towards us look at this I'm
actually very careful with my car
because I don't want these about to
charge me now I think they're a little
bit of a nervous side so this is not
ideal because the water's not
particularly deep so I don't think they
feel very safe in it and this big male
hippo in front is a hippo we see on a
regular basis in he has a - pose a pet
name which is scuba Steve and he's quite
a shy hippopotamus so he does sorry
hippos I didn't mean to give you a
fright
was he we're quite far away from them
and then that car is just following in
suit and this is where these creatures
can become extremely dangerous so you're
also got to be careful of hippos
charging your vehicle so I'm gonna leave
them because I didn't want them to leave
the water the fact that they got out of
the water again look if you in case you
have never seen bubbles of dam it's all
the way down over there but it's very
very shallow at the moment so I'm gonna
keep going and just let those hippos
come back to the water where they do
feel a lot safer if it was not Scuba
Steve if it was that Carl by herself and
maybe another hippo ball I don't think
they would have got us I just know that
it's in that males nature he's very very
nervous he hasn't got any confidence at
all
yes Roslyn typos only deadly there or
more people than the big VY put together
so you gotta watch out for them and they
obviously they're just wild animals and
as you've just seen even though they're
so massive there can be you know scaredy
cats
and I think sham I feel likes a lot of
the time when people end up getting
injured is because they're just they're
so frightened of us as humans and
they're protective over their areas
their whole territories so if I were to
go anywhere near that water and in foot
on a car and he was happy you could
quite happy turn around and attack me
and there's nothing wrong with him doing
that he's just protecting what's and
like I said because there's not much
water in there he's just not feeling
particularly comfortable I think he
feels quite vulnerable that maybe I
could run in there and easily attack him
not but I'd want to do something like
that but maybe that's what he thinks in
his mind right so he didn't pick up on
any fresh signs of Sandy just some old
tracks from where she came in to avoid
Taylor this morning but a Tristan man
has managed to sort out his gremlins and
he's still with us on earth
[Music]
indeed now sorry about a little bit
earlier we had a slight technical
difficulty like you were so close to
camp that we could shoot in like a
Formula One pitstop crew and get
everything sorted out and back art again
to be able to spend some time with our
favorite ways and I've just moved a
little bit from where he last was he's
his legs were in the Sun so he got hot
feet and he needed to kind of reposition
himself so he's put himself in the shade
now and that didn't go down well with
the local squirrel population in the
neighborhood as they were all shouting
at him and then also he's kind of now
just looking around they were a few
impalas around as well so he's just kind
of scanning about and he's was a little
bit of a breeze that's kind of blowing
into his face so he looks quite content
doesn't he is about as happy as you
could ever imagine for a lipid he's but
a full tummy is a bit of a breeze
blowing he's got some shade and he's got
some company which we know Masana
likes to have so typical of him to be
kind of around where he is now Gallagher
pan is one of his favourite little horns
to be able to not only race but get
water and to be able to hunt potential
food items that have come this way and I
was a bit worried a little earlier
because I thought potentially the Indies
might have pushed him off and moved him
from this area because they seemed to
have come from here and when ILI's are
around they sometimes can make lipids
move and that's maybe why he's lying
here and not in the drainage line or
caligo pan because of the fact that the
alias moves through there they might
have just made him move kind of a little
bit art and so he's found the next best
place with some shade
conveniently one meter over the road so
finding him really was not tricky this
afternoon at all now it's been a very
very very very busy week for husana he's
been all over the place and well he had
a tough time of it trying to defend his
meal that he had in the middle of the
week
we find hasana on a hot afternoon with
the fresh niala kill he barely had time
to catch his breath when a hyena
approached the kill little chief grab
the Nuala carcass and with all his might
tried to hold a huge kill up a tree alas
he just wasn't strong enough to get the
carcass to safety before cozy a male
hyena ran in and latched on to the
carcass Masana realizing he was no match
for lino it go and disgust causar
proceeded to drag the carcass a short
distance away before tucking into his
stolen meal Isana was helpless but
patient as he lay panting looking for
any gap to retrieve his meal
unfortunately for the Prince the noise
of crushing bone attracted another
member of the Juma clan and Timur
bounded in to join in the festivities
with the two hyenas preoccupied Masana
spotted a piece and like a flash ran in
unfortunately it wasn't fast enough
was promptly chased off the scene by
lioness well wasn't that a tough time
for Busan I felt so bad for him he had
done so well to find himself a meal and
then unfortunately they stole it from
him and he was left not to get any of it
although it seems as though the next
morning Taylor went back and she managed
to find him sort of noshing on a leg or
something like that and so maybe got a
little little piece out of it and was
able to then kind of eat that but it
really did feel sorry for him it's it's
tough Archer when his hyenas and other
lipids that steal from you and so
personas had to learn that the hard way
this year he really has had a difficult
time of it in terms of thievery the
thing is though is that he did
everything right there it was just
unfortunate circumstance and also a
problem that he killed something that
was a little too large for his size at
this stage if he had killed something
smaller he would have done everything
right he would have been into the tree
with his caucus and everything would
have been okay but because he killed a
large animal it makes it a lot trickier
for him to have gotten it up but he you
know he killed it he dragged it to the
base of a tree before any heiner's and
arrived he sat they was just catching
his breath he was starting to kind of
eat it a little bit open it up trying to
lighten it and unfortunately he just got
caught too early on and that happens
from time to time even to the most
experienced of lipids I've seen them
lose kills like that the only thing is I
think he could have been more aggressive
potentially towards a male how you know
that he saw you know he's suppose you
still on the younger side but a big male
lipid might not have stood down to a
small you know male hyena of course his
size and he might have been try to take
it back but you know he ran to the tree
picked it up before that you know came
he tried to get it up but it was just
literally too heavy he tried with all
his strength to get it up there and then
you know this is just the way it goes
I've seen many many many leopards lose
kills like that's including big males
liked in Ghana who just don't have the
time frame to get it up and struggle
with that carcass all the way up the
tree and so like I say he did everything
right and he's experienced to try and
put it up into the tree was there but
unfortunately and this is the way it
goes sometimes and they lose out but
asana will learn from that and hopefully
be able to get it right next time anyway
talking about hyenas it's Steve sounds
like he's having a wonderful afternoon
in the company of the North grin and
well they are not as thieving as lion is
down here they do a lot of work of their
own three Mahina joined the scene and
now all the youngsters have come out
who've seen for now three three running
around now these two but very excited
avenge this probably mum that arrived
back it's very hard I'm getting very
confused because all the youngsters are
playing with all the mothers and running
around and almost suckling of everyone
they are doing a little bit of pasting
again very important life lessons to
learn these two are much smaller than
what forces ones you can see they don't
even have any spots yet on the chest you
see that a completely dark in color he's
doing the pasting here we go not a very
successful one at the back there but
that's why we practice and it was doing
a little bit of digging as well before
the holes not big enough
it says to mum what's going on in their
head with that nose but can you smell
little one feeling a lot more confident
that there's more adults around
maybe it's a good question that's all
got to do with the researches and what
sort of money they have funding is
always important and colouring of an
individual costs money because you've
got a dart then which means you need to
vet and then you need to collect
probably a new one so yeah I definitely
it's one of those questions I'll have to
ask the researchers when I see them but
it depends on how long they want their
study to go for one matriarch might be
enough for them they might have got
enough data by the nce can see four of
them now it's just all over the show for
really small youngsters and then one
that's up at the top there's got a
little bit more spots on it their heads
do a little bit more darker you can see
the spots a little bit more on the chest
then the one in France it's pasting one
of the Sabbats pasted on that branch
before and well there we go a little bit
of love a little bit of a fiction in the
hyena world
now this one is allowing one to suckle
so I don't know what's going on and wit
through cards to the youngsters they all
over the place with the adults falling
in the hole running around pasting
greeting everybody very exciting time
for them they've been in the ground for
quite some time you see these two
they've got a lot more spots on the
chest slowly slowly coming through Megan
hyena camps as well as wild dog cubs are
born black purely because they get very
very sorry there was a zebra behind us
they're having a little bit of a fight
to keep them warmer and black fur
actually is much warmer than white fur
and so when they're in the hole they
they stay a little bit warmer than they
do if they're working a lighter color I
think that's the main reason and slowly
over time they will generate those spots
lion cubs on the other hand are much
lighter in color but more camouflaged
they don't have a hole to hide in so
maybe the blackness is also too too
the youngsters in the hole from
predators they can go quite deep in
there and they sort of blend in with the
shadows and also the the black is to
keep them warm this my my thoughts
anyway where's lion and leopard cubs
generally just secrets it under a bush
somewhere and well they need the spots
to keep them there quite nice and well
hidden they don't have the benefit while
they hole in the ground and just look at
how this is all playing out in front of
us the zebra and wildebeest are not
bothered at all and an entire family of
hyena doing their thing
Monique myself personally I have no idea
they've all got pseudo penises and they
all have what looks like genitals which
is one of those things you get in hyena
society and it's only after maybe a
little while when they get little bit
bigger you'll start to be able to tell
who is the mountain who is the female
for example that one is busy playing
with its anal gland if you can see that
really interesting movement there well
charming indeed warrants a sniff doesn't
it yes everything in HoN hyena society
is about the nose
okay well we're starting to get a little
whiffed of behind you then itself as the
wind changes its course but oh hi you
know I've been active and I think
Tristan is still with a little chief
let's see if he's going to wake up
anytime soon husana is very sleepy and I
don't expect anything less he's been a
sleepy kitty for much of the afternoon
given it's quite warm and he was fairly
active when we actually found him this
morning he kind of woke up and walked
around and we stayed for it with him a
bit off to drive just to see where you'd
end up and he was still going and
stalking and scent-marking and he was
heavily scent-marking he must have sent
marked at least six or seven times in
about a 200 meter stretch of road so he
was marking every tree side of the road
scraping his back legs like we saw him
do kind of in the middle of the week and
so you know he's kind of been an active
boy this this morning and I'm not
surprised in that he needs a little bit
of a nap I would imagine what we're
gonna see from him is he's gonna sleep
like this as that Sun starts get a
little bit lower he's gonna make his way
down to the pan for a little drink and
then from there who knows where he's
gonna hit I have a sneaky suspicion
you'll just romp a kind of drainage line
and head off towards for your Atilla pan
the one in front of the camp with the
damn camp and it's going to have a
little look around there maybe try and
do some hunting and from there it's
anyone's guess as to where he goes
hopefully spends the night in that area
and tries to hunt and he'll be around
tomorrow morning that's what I'm kind of
hoping will happen but they'll just have
to see how it goes
as they no not really not from anything
in particular though he's waking up now
because a little vehicle is joining us
on the sighting and so that's why he's
just kind of having a bit of a stretch
but no he's not really vulnerable I mean
theoretically the only things that he's
gotta worry about is Big Bear lipids or
lions and both of those will probably
see sleeping just like he is at the
moment he's also got a tree right next
to him if if potentially a clan of
hyenas are to come past you'd be able
just to run straight up that tree there
and kind of go in for safety so he's
definitely got options but no he's not
vulnerable it's just you know we often
think of lipids as shy secretive animals
and while for the most part they are
when they left to their own devices or
are very relaxed and a bit shaded like
these leopards are we get to see that
they actually don't mind sleeping right
arts in the open where they can kind of
see what's going on around them just as
much as any other animal so you know
they they know what they're doing asanas
you know it's even though he's young in
his life he's still experienced with
lots and to survive to the point that he
has given that he was orphaned at such a
young age it's pretty incredible where
he is and he'll of nowhere is safe and
where isn't and in this particular area
that we're in it's probably the central
point of ting Ghana's territory and so
that's why he'll be feeling quite safe
cats how do we identify these leopards
well there's a number of ways to do it
cats spots are pretty much the best way
in the only way scientifically to really
kind of do it and what you'll use as you
either use those spots you see he's got
three little spots over the top of his
whiskers you see there's there's black
lines where the whiskers come out and
just above that are three little black
spots one very close to his nose and
then two close together but further away
now all those will be a three on his
right side then on his left side yo says
three spots so that would mean that he
is what we would call a three three male
now the arrangement of those spots is
different on every single leopard it's
much like a fingerprint you'll have
different kind of spots completely as
well as his facial markings in his body
the spots will be different to any other
leopard that is at the end so if you get
different kind of spots and you can
match them against others you can
recognize it but how we recognize them
because we are fortunate enough to see a
lot of these lipids as often as we do we
often can recognize them just clearly or
by sight so what they look like much
like you maybe have a domestic animal at
home if you have a dog or a cat and you
would be able to know which one is your
dog or cat because you've seen it so
many times and you get to recognize
certain traits within them and it's the
same thing with these guises once you
see them a lot you recognize eye color
you recognize body shape and certain
little things that will give it away
that will tell you who the slip it is
and so I mean spots are the scientific
way but Archer very seldom do I look at
a lipid spots before we know who it is
just the general sort of appearance of
that animal the way it looks its facial
kind of features its eye color its ears
that will all kind of tell you who
exactly
it is but spots are the one that you
should really kind of use if you are to
do things properly and each like I say
each lipid will have a completely
different support pattern to another one
that's very very very sleepy cat but
well we're sitting here with her son are
we going to hope that he's going to wake
up and get going for the afternoon but
while we do that could send you back
Ross - Taylor who I'm sure is just
driving around trying to find a Tandy
and Columbia and hopefully she'll get
some luck soon so we gave up on
searching for Tandy and tell amber I
don't know where that are so what we did
is he came all the way down and along
the eastern boundary and then down to
the south and we're trying to find one
of the Avoca male lions who was seen
here this morning with Tristan but I
don't see him anymore so I'm wondering
if he hasn't maybe moved off
so he was she was sleeping around here
somewhere he's got a bad limp so I don't
think you'd be going too far I'm just
gonna quickly keep checking the shady
touches in case I missed him if you did
watch a sunrise Safari this morning and
you saw the interaction between the
Avoca male and ting gana you really
realize half flat a lion can make itself
okay let me just check here to make sure
that there is nothing
I won't have to end up going back up
again yes I think we will do quickly
just check one more time along here
anyways something else that we could see
around and in this area that have been
popping up over the last week or so is
the wild dogs and we did have a
spectacular sighting of them just a few
days ago the Ambala invest tech
breakaway pack and they puppies showed
up on our western boundary and it's hard
to get a total count of the dogs as they
were lying up in some long grass
eventually one of the pack members
initiated a game with one of the other
dogs but an intruder arrived on scene
immediately adults went into defense
mode and the puppies raced off to safety
the hyena eventually moved off and left
the pack in peace
sadly it seems as though two of the
puppies have not made it only four
remain I have no doubt that that all to
do their very best to keep the remaining
pups alive alright it because that we've
been so fortunate to have the awesome
dogs on the property and I hope that
they come back that could be something
else if all hope fails today we might
have to head down towards the waist
we're checking all quadrants of the of
the reserve at the moment I care haven't
seen the dog tracks though I haven't
heard anything I'm just all just looking
for that lion he's here somewhere
giraffe girl you have exclaimed and
you're excited about all the wild dogs
yes I also do enjoy them they're all
really lovely when they're around I just
can't believe how big those puppies are
getting to their enormous feel like
they've doubled in size but nothing
stays little for very long out yeah it's
important that they all grow nice and
big and strong sorry I'm still just
checking here for the lion I'm going all
the way down to the boundary now I'm
sure he's here somewhere just in the
shade okay wonderful okay we're gonna do
some proper searching and just check the
shadows very carefully to find this
Avoca male that's lying somewhere around
yeah or if you go back to Steve who's
waiting patiently as I hide it in well
we are still here we were thinking of
leaving but you can't leave and all the
little ones come out who have been very
active as always most active I've seen
them tasting hmm some growls going on
there see if you can hear it
that's about all it's getting a bit too
close the female and the whole is not
lacking the attention youngsters are
trying to figure out what's a growling
all about getting them quite excited my
safari very good question
my knowledge of animals and their teeth
needs a little bit of work so I'm going
to pose a question to the viewers how
many teeth do hyena have I'm going to
reckon it's in the thirties
some way around there but the exact
number I am not sure at the moment every
day it's good to add some knowledge to
our to our minds and what I do know is
that their bite force is incredible and
look at that look at those teeth there
they are enormous centre your questions
or comments two hashtags of foil average
is popular on YouTube stream who can
tell us how many teeth does the average
eye in a have Peggy hyena have got that
reputation of being a scavenger and yes
they do scavenge but they are very adept
at killing their own prey catching their
own food and in their clans they pick
out the weak and then will actually
physically chase it down and bite it
very similar to the way wild dogs do
bite its invited and eventually subdue
it the animal eventually dies of blood
loss and shock as it gets eaten alive
so very very within fast-moving animals
they can keep up a good pace and they're
pretty much just run the animal into the
ground but generally selecting the
weakest individual Brent had in what a
few months ago I think in February had
the happy zebra clan catching a a topi
that was quite something to behold at
something I'm quite looking forward to
our chair down in South Africa we seem
to only find the hyena scavenging and
following the likes of asana and ting
gana around but not necessarily doing
the killing themselves but we don't get
to see it we don't get to spend the time
excuse me up here we're not
really supposed to be following hyena so
we've got them by the den site so to see
what they're doing and where they're
going and how they hunt very difficult
but I know Brent
Jamie and Scott have all had some really
epic sightings of the hyena doing all
sorts of things and also are competing
lion which is something that's quite
tricky to do Laurie you know what want
to know tasting is well if you have a
look at the youngsters there let's go
back to the youngsters it on the right
of this this medium-sized one here James
there's that little little branch there
just done yeah I see a little branch to
the right of this one individual see if
I could put my finger on it you know
there we go that branch right there
there we go that one well in and around
a den site youngsters or practice
pasting so I mean I've got an anal gland
and when adults move around in their
territories and in lawn long distances
away from the den they've got specific
sort of signposts and areas where
they'll they'll paste so they'll
basically rub their bottom the anal
gland on top of the branch or the stalk
or whatever it might be and that gives
off all sorts of communication signals
to their clan to other clans that sort
of advertiser's occupancy it's similar
to what leopards do in their urine spray
except the paste lasts a lot longer and
people postulate that the smell or the
the paste itself can indicate the sexual
maturity a little bit of our Jabbar ji a
sexual maturity strength size
reproductive ability of the clan we can
only guess but the pasting needs to be
redone every couple of weeks and in and
around a den site the youngsters will
practice now do it religiously almost it
becomes very instinctive for them
because when they're out in the field
they need to be able to do it at some
stage at those signposts where they also
defecate yes indeed that zebras got a
lot to say this afternoon so the pasting
is something that the youngsters
practice and we've probably seen a few
you've probably seen a few clips or in
that one clip and earlier we saw the
answer sort of if you've got a dog at
home and they walk around
they're up their bum on the carpet
because they've got worms well let's
kind of what pasting looks like in these
individuals they lift up their tail and
they're up there anal gland onto a small
stalk that's a little bit elevated off
the ground and then that gives off a
communication signal which lasts for two
weeks
which gives off a really really pungent
smell if you ever do happen to come
across one well it seems like Limpy
Luton has been found let's go to Taylor
who would like to show you the battered
old gentleman here is Limpy loo one of
the Avoca
boys I cannot believe is the size he is
these guys have like I'm not even joking
doubled in size not only in in body mass
but also if their manes
it's just absolutely extraordinary how
how quickly these animals grown we were
literally just talking about how nothing
stays little forever and of course that
applies to these males
now the Avoca boys have been an
interesting coalition of males that have
come from from the north and we haven't
been seeing them too often they popped
their noses on every now and then but
they haven't quite established
themselves up here in the north since
the birmingham boys moved on further
south and there's no sign of the
birmingham males coalition that were up
here returning anytime soon so i think
so d but Rudy once the Evoque is
realized that the space is really now
open and and up for grabs they'll start
moving on in they've got a hard job of
trying to convince the females and the
prides within the area that they're
worthy it'll take a little bit of time
but eventually they'll worm their way in
which is not normally happens it's not a
typical quick thing the female lions are
you know slow to gain the trust of
others fair enough but luckily for the
in Kahuna's is that they don't have any
young cubs and the only real issue that
they could and occur within the pride is
that these boys chase aren't young in
Kakuma male and then also well his his
fellowship now because he
got three others that have decided they
quite liked him too and would also want
to join his coalition so they might not
tolerate them anymore
but while they're not permanently here
in the northern sabi sands it seems you
spending a time more on the money laity
and in puffles hook which is just north
of us I reckon in the next few months
they'll probably settle on down it also
sounds like there's been a couple of
lionesses I don't know who which lioness
is mating with him from the Inca home
abroad there for years shame I'm not
sure what's happened to this male line
but he's been limping for a couple of
days now and and Tristan was saying to
me it looks like one of his joints is
quite swollen so I suppose we can really
only speculate whether it's a snake bar
whether he's run after something and
he's you know twisted a joint that
happens you know what it's like when you
twist your ankle and how swollen your
leg becomes these kinds of injuries are
fairly common but the animals especially
if you're running at full speed you're
not particularly looking at where your
feet are going but the amount of holes
and things like that yeah you know I
suppose anything could happen and that
does look a little bit swollen they're
just on their joint so it could be a cut
that's maybe got infected something like
that could cause some serious swelling
too but it's a very minor injury for for
this boy we've seen animals for example
just talking about the Inca Houma pride
again
look at that lioness that had that
monstrous gash on her hind leg and how
she's completely recovered and she
looked really really terrible at one
point she was thin she had no muscle
even though she was eating on a regular
basis and she's quite a severe number
two but she's fine now so these animals
are a lot more resilient than we think
and we need to give them credit where
credit's due and healing is definitely
one of them and if they're not strong
enough to survive our chair to survive
everything that's thrown at them their
nature deems I'm not worthy of living
and I know that sounds sad to you and I
but that's just how it works our chair
in the wild wild west
but he's probably going to do what a
lion does he's going to just rest up and
he's kind of in the fork of a road what
a t-junction if you will an animal
pathway and then a fire break we'll see
John watch this fellow and hopefully
he'll do a rollover and open those
beautiful golden eyes for us to see
another boy that's got beautiful golden
eyes but is keeping them tightly shut
his husana indeed our golden eyes run in
golden eyes he's our golden cat really
in many respects and he's also having a
very big nap I think it's all of the
cats were so busy this morning that they
decided it's time to kind of rest I'm
pretty sure that they will get going
it's starting to cool down quite nicely
and knowing horse honor this is just
before the time he starts to get going
he normally starts to get going at about
sort of Hoppus 5:00 that's his normal
kind of time he likes to wonder just
before that Sun sets and then he kind of
wanders around at sunset itself so I
expect him to wake up fairly soon I'm
hoping he will at least and provide us
with some epic epic entertainment as he
net generally does in the moment though
it's a little bit of a sleepy cat he
kind of his taking it very easy and just
digesting thats stolen kill of his that
he got from shadaloo he ate that for a
few days and so his tummy is really nice
and bulgy
but knowing what's on or - he's not
going to just sit down tonight and not
hunt he just has a bottomless pit for a
stomach and so pretty sure he's going to
try and find some semblance of food
during the night you can see he's
dreaming he's a little touching of his
toes what are you chasing boy obviously
dreaming he's chasing something is the
front foot is also twitching now as well
so he's such a silly cat it really is
it's been amazing kind of following him
over the past few months I don't think
we've had could have asked for anything
better we've been so spoiled with how
many things he's provided in terms of
unique behavior in terms of just general
kind of goofiness that's you wouldn't
really expect from a leopard and to get
to know leopard the way we have with him
has been very very very special we've
had the most amazing time with
but so Andy minutes depends is obviously
it depends on weather conditions a lot
of the time also depends on what's
around him and what opportunities come
their way so you know if there's hunting
opportunities but generally you'll find
a leopard will sleep for anywhere
between sort of 14 and 18 hours a day
maybe even sometimes more than that it
depends on how full they are whether
they've got food all of these kind of
things some cats are more active cat
like asana he tends to move a lot you
know you see him moving around quite a
bit when he's not hunting or feeding
when he's hunting at these pans then he
sits there all night but I mean or when
he's feeding he stays there but
otherwise you can see kind of walks a
lot I mean the other day we found he was
seen at 4-4 suktam didn't afternoon me
then found him very close to camp he
then walked all the way back to before
sup dam in the following morning he had
walked from buffers of dam to the south
western corner which is on the opposite
end from where before Zach damaged so
he'd covered huge amount of distance
during that time and that would have
meant that he didn't actually sleep as
much so you know that just depends on
the day and but on average I would say
between sort of maybe 12 and 18 hours
would be my kind of range for a leopard
a far more active than the Lions taylors
lion and she's got he's probably more
around 20 hours now I was saying early
in the week that he had a busy time as
he walked about all over the place and
we've also discussed how he always is
involved in shenanigans and well we had
a pretty entertaining sighting of him as
he tried to take on a ferocious lizard
after losing our to value know the
little chief was on the prowl for
another meal hidden in the grass was a
large monitor lizzard sana approached to
investigate little did he know he had
come up against a worthy adversary
monitor lashed out of teeth and a
whipping tail
realizing discretion was the better part
of valor Hassan has strutted off leaving
the brave lizard to fight another day
the little scent marking done the prince
decided to flop down who is either bored
or decided a bit of practice was in
order as soon he swatted and played with
a stick perhaps next time the monitor
won't be so lucky if his ninja technique
finally chew well yes the ninja chop
that he's practiced now on the stick
that monitor lizzard better watch out
next time because now he's honed his
skills it was very funny watching him
playing around with that stick I didn't
laugh a lot and actually it was a lost
drive with veer mark one of our camera
operators and VM wanted him to play with
the stick when we started the drive and
we somehow managed to actually get it on
camera it's very very cute he is such a
goofball this cats often just doing
these kind of things where he misses
about and does all kinds of random stuff
with sticks and branches and grass and
really kind of just goes crazy at times
I thoroughly thoroughly enjoy watching
him when he's like that he really kind
of makes me laugh he you can see that
youthfulness is still in him when he
does those kind of things it's not like
you know ting honor ting on all very
seldom miss around with a stick or
something like that where's husana he
tends to just play all the time and
sometimes even gets the crazies where he
just runs around like a hooligan round
in circles and up and down and grabs
things and it's pretty funny because you
see that a lot in domestic cats
particularly younger domestic cats and
so he's in many respects that way as
well he kind of does these kind of
things and he really is a crazy crazy
individual I thoroughly kind of enjoy
following him around and seeing what he
gets up to he's difficult not to like
wasana so even if you're not a leopard
fan spending time with him and watching
his antics really kind of has to endear
you to him as an individual like I say
if you're not really a lipid Vernice
cool an individual and personality in
terms of a cat personality that you
can't help but be attracted to he brings
a smile to most people's faces and it's
really interesting because obviously you
know we spend a lot of time with him
probably far more than anybody else
archer but we often get to speak to
guests that have been around and that
have seen him and you know to the
various landowners these areas
and I've yet to meet somebody are you
not talking
asana in your sleep I have yet to meet
somebody that hasn't Absolut's loved
spending time with his cats and hasn't
kind of walked away with saying what a
special cat is that you really is quite
incredible even when he's sleeping he
can provide entertainment by talking to
us in his dreams I wonder what he would
say if he was actually sitting here and
taking it easy I know he's gonna do a
big stretch his stretches of good news
we want to see stretches like that
because it means he's starting to kind
of stir little bits they'll be
infrequent to start with but as he
starts to wake up so they'll more and
more will happen right now hopefully it
is a good sign that he is going to start
waking up but from one sleeping cat to
another let's send you back across to
Taylor mccurdy I think he's gonna be
sleepy for quite some time
he hasn't even blinked his eyes once
since we've been here they've been close
he's nice and tight I think he's
enjoying the cool afternoon breeze as
long as well as with the Oh Craig look
at that unsuspecting water back it's
just over there now there's a water back
that's walking up it's still quite far
away I don't think that this line is
going to get up and hunter although she
seems to be quite suspicious or
something the wind is swirling this
afternoon she she's unsure she's looking
the wrong way but something definitely
caught her attention no cerissa he looks
like he he ate in the last few days so I
don't think he needs to worry about it
too much but the idea behind the
digestive system of predators is that
they can actually go a couple of days
without eating so they gorge themselves
so that they look like they've eaten a
beach ball and that will take a couple
of days to digest so three or four days
is fine I've ever seen lines that
haven't eaten for a week week and a half
then they start to look fairly fairly
thin but then they normally catch
something in in due time now she just
stood
on a branch I heard it crack and he
didn't even lift his head up and
acknowledge her and if I can hear that
water back and you know cracking as she
steps on on branches then surely that
male lion will be able to hear it easily
but he's not interested he's fast asleep
she's still looking around very
uncertain but she knows that something
is up she's acting like she's being
quite suspicious even though that male
lion has got an injury in his limping
adrenalin is an incredible thing and
I've seen animals with broken legs get
up and run like there's nothing wrong
with him so if he was absolutely
desperate and reven us and needed
something to eat well then you probably
wouldn't act like he had a sore leg
anymore which is difficult because he is
unlucky and he doesn't have the
lionesses to help him so he's still got
to work on that but maybe he'll catch up
with his brothers a little bit later but
it seems as though the weather is
changing in the Mara and it seems as
though a storm has started to brew the
weather in the distance is definitely
raining we saw it on our way that's why
we decided not to go too far south that
is kind of the area over there way
that's the Salt Lick area and that
general direction a little bit more to
the right is where the sausage tree
pride and and hanging out it was very
very wet down that side but beautiful
beautiful scenes this is the view from
the hyena den and swathe with animals
over the horizon they've picked a really
good real estate here very nice
vegetation brings in the herds but just
like Limpy Lou neither the prey animal
or the predator here looks very
interested in each other all the beer
stop are moaning constantly but there's
no sort of animosity between these two
maybe when the light goes down I always
find it amazing because I mean I you
know are known to actually kill and
catch
of their food up here and what they do
is steal every now and again their steal
the food and every now and again it is
them who wins against the Lions and
sometimes it's the lions who went
against the hyena but sometimes male
lions have interactions with themselves
we came across Kapoor Lee in the late
afternoon far south near the Salt Lake
area it came as no surprise then to find
him with the Salt Lick pride sleeping
off a meal delivered by the Sears
migration the old veteran looked rather
beaten up with blood oozing from a hole
below a very swollen right eye as the
temperatures cooled each lioness took a
turn to greet and investigate the
battle-scarred male in characteristic
line fashion as Capote looked on the
pride mounted off one by one into the
darkening night can you imagine having a
hole in your face over here everybody
take your finger and just feel that area
imagine a hole like this big right on
your face even James is feeling it I
can't be very nice and Kapoor Lee was
wearing that like a battle-scarred
gentleman with the Salt Lick pride they
all very very keen to go over to him and
give him a proper little I can think of
nothing worse you've got this injury
everybody wants to rub but that's but
it's like having an older brother when
you got a bruise all he does is he wants
to push that bruise deliberately oh
what's that
anyway the herds in the open plains
whereabouts are the Salt Lick pride
they're out there somewhere Kapoor Lee
is out there probably with the herds
spread out throughout the entire area
and very difficult to track them down
but tomorrow myself and almost a big
James are we gonna go and spend some
time down in the south and see if we can
track down any lions the general game
from what we've noticed in the last few
days all seems to have moved towards the
river port more north --is-- north and
east but there is still lots of general
game down that side there's huge areas
that were burnt
so I think today we're just gonna have
to have to play with it and see where we
go now definitely many many lions are
there but the prey are just in abundance
it is mind boggling folks I I actually
wanted to do a video myself as you came
out this afternoon because they were
just so many animals well it seems like
the the little chief has woken up and
let's go see what he's up to look at him
he's transformed into another spotted
creature this is Athena no I'm joking
poor husana has just been chased by this
how you know I don't know where he is I
don't know if he's actually under the
car because the last time I saw him is
walking to the bonnet and I didn't see
him come out so I'm not sure if he's
actually underneath the car or not so
please excuse me while I just look and
make sure I saw no you under there no no
it doesn't sound like it let's just have
a little look I starts your shoots out
to it I'm just gonna go back in case
because he's so relaxed sometimes you
might actually be able to know that's
good I think he must have gone round the
man but it does how you know it came out
at the worst possible time because it's
now stopped him from having a drink he
was about to go and have a lovely drink
and now instead he's parked himself off
and is watching with disdain and
staggers in his eyes as this hyena
drinks the water that he wanted to go
and have and now you know that was he
looked like it was Corky then she's very
very very full and I think it was her
it's either Corky or pretty but it
looked like Corky to me I didn't get a
greatest of look because I was kind of
watch her husana was going it looks like
her and so she's full and and coming for
a drink which means I think she's maybe
come from which then she's using but the
fact that she's arrived at Galago pan
tends to suggest to me that she's moved
either to this or breezed in with the
Gallagher shortcut in because that's the
closest to to this area I wouldn't
expect her to be coming from the villa
monster den she should have gone to tree
house if that's where she was going to
go and drink with look at this him D not
the most regal cat when he sits like
this interestingly enough he's once
again
Sint marking and making a lot of kind of
scraping with the back legs which is a
new thing for husana knees
days is very seldom we had seen him
doing it before this week but he seems
very confident and is scraping all over
the place like a dropper lipid would do
and his scent marking bushes and lifting
his tail and it's not just lifting and
pretending he's seriously spraying he's
not just you know a few little Jets of
urine his massive amounts of urine
that's are actually being kind of
sprayed now Paul husana I'm sorry boy a
few a thirsty that hyenas now wallowing
say Hassan has got no Jones you can see
look eyes just watching that hyenas if
to say what are you doing it my water I
was thirsty now I have to wait for you
not only to get out but also to defecate
and urinate in my water and make it all
stinky that is a look of not impressed
at all is it a funny cat the expressions
on his face sometimes the university is
for the most part younger leopards tend
to sleep less then older ones all the
leopards you know as they get tired they
generally are well established their
territories are fairly well marked
already and so there's no real need for
them to move around too much and younger
lipids seem to have you know but more
energy to burn it's much like kids
versus adults you know kids will run
around all day long and whereas you know
adults tend to for the most part be a
little bit more lethargic than a kid or
a little bit more measured should we put
it in their approach to life then what
kids on it's very much the same with
young animals it's not just leopard its
Lions it's you know cheetah
hyenas all of these kind of animals the
young ones tend to run around in foots
of extreme energy very quickly and it's
because most of the time they're not
actually having to provide for
themselves they can take it fairly easy
they get fed and therefore they can burn
energy at a rate of knots and not have
to stress too much whereas older cats
you know they know that every time they
run around like a hooligan they've
actually got to replace that energy and
so therefore more measured in what they
do but isn't that just a stare of notice
on are you an impressed boy
right well he looks very unimpressed and
I'm not surprised Inez kind of drifted
in and this is not the first time we've
seen this unimpressed look this week at
the beginning of the week it's in Ghana
husana and home for Kazi all had
unimpressed looks of the iron we find
the little prince perched on top of the
termite mound on a blustery afternoon he
is staring into the distance and we soon
see why another leopard is up a tree
some four Kazi the newcomer and he has
managed to achieve his kill from asana
the next morning sun is still in
attendance but the figure looming behind
him in the tree is a large and more
intimidating one whom [ __ ] Ozzy has
clearly been despatched but by who the
relaxed nature of asana under the tree
indicates it can only be one king Ghana
it seems father and son have teamed up
to chase the newcomer away however now
that dad has a chance to feed leaves his
son to try and fend off I mean is on the
ground Prince snarls and keeps one of
the clan at bay while watching his dad
as if to say pass me some to
unfortunately father/son bonding time is
cut short as more of the Juma clan
arrive come son is forced to ascend in
the about marilla treat pain is
everywhere asana settles in for a short
nap while his dad's in ghana watches
they receive the prize of his people
wasn't that amazing amazing first of all
that we got such a good view of him for
kasi because we know he can be a little
on the shy side so that was super cool
and then obviously to have father and
son kind of team up and I just that one
kind of shot of husana on the mound and
to ghana behind him on the tree was just
so magical it was one of those very very
special kind of shots that we get and
Craig did sterling sterling work to
actually capture that's a very very very
cool to see and super fortunate that we
got to see all three of them for you of
one Impala car because it goes to show
you I wonder how often that happens that
we find you know lipids on carcasses and
half and they've actually been stolen by
others it's probably more often than we
actually think particularly with
transient males when there's big
dominant males around you would imagine
that this is what would happen and and
you'd think that you know these males
obviously kind of pushing vie for
territory and so thievery amongst them
must be quite high but hassanis
reactions through that whole sighting
we're absolutely priceless he first had
to go and kind of stole it that morning
and then in the afternoon and for cause
he had it back and then you know he then
set the next morning waiting for ting
garlic to kind of drop him scraps with
this kind of begging look on his face
that's only Hosanna can have shame boy
is your waterhole being occupied by ena
yes looks that way he does not look
impressed at all by all of this so our
wide eyed boy is still watching what's
going on and so while he does that send
you across to teyla mccurdy who's now
traded in the lodges cat for the largest
animal miss Yaga
I traded in a cat for my favorite animal
in the whole wide world which was not a
bad trade in my books
the a said line did not know how he was
going to wake up anytime soon he was
fast asleep and then we're very lucky to
stumble across a herd of elephants there
are a lot more active now if a veil
offense moved through where that lion
was he definitely become a whole bunch
more active but I think that that was
going to be the case he's caught no
teeny tiny car for a couple of years old
looking close to mom just feeding away
looking for things to nibble up but he's
in much for them it's very very tough at
the moment that's a small herd might be
part of it a big herd Tony I haven't
actually seen that many elephant calves
at all I've been saying on the drives
how I've been you know a lacking seeing
a herd of elephants and hoping to find a
herd you know of a you know twenty or
thirty of them and then spend quite a
bit of time with them but unfortunately
that has not been possible because I
haven't found him yet so this is a
relatively small group pretty much that
little one we're looking at is the
youngest elephant and the herd the rest
are all much older and they don't think
too worried there's mom I'm interested
to see where mom's going to go and she
seemed fairly relaxed with us which was
quite nice so we'll just go with it at
the moment she does approach us and she
shows us that she's unhappy well move
out of her way dick you'd love the
sighting me too and I'm so happy to
share it with you I think it is so
awesome very peaceful very very very
peaceful and the light is just
absolutely gorgeous at the moment too so
that definitely helps I all said miles I
always said I said often there's nothing
quite like a sighting with elephants
just have they a way about them and
you're pretty much absorbent and my
favorite thing is to actually watch
elephants eyes
and the way that they stare at you
they're so soulful Julie I'm so glad
that you are happy to see these Eddie's
I promise you I'm just as excited as you
are I think she's got beautiful amber
eyes lovely long lashes and also just to
see all those folds and this skin is
just beautiful they are particularly
wrinkly creatures don't you think isn't
that nice and do you think their texture
is just absolutely beautiful and it is
best suited of course on an elephant it
shouldn't be seen anywhere else other
than on these wonderful creatures
doesn't look like they've had a drink
just yet so then there might be making
their way maybe towards a little Gauri
they also have a pumped pan there now
Daniel
obviously and we can look at this
younger elephant and because you've
asked about how long it takes for them
to be able to utilize their trunks
properly and it does take them a bit of
time so our about a year they're getting
the hang of it but I'd say up to about
two years or so they're gonna be
struggling and they're gonna get
stronger and stronger as they go and
we'll definitely take quite a few years
for them only once they're fully grown
or are they you know have trained most
of those muscles so you'll see every now
and then this elephant will struggle a
little bit but predominantly it has got
the hang of being able to find the
smaller things and pick them up and eat
them and not too worried to be away from
mum either happy to walk around by
itself shame poor horse Anna is just
being pestered by his least favourite
animal in the wild well he is
unfortunately though we just missed it
the hyena just went around the termite
mound and yet to kind of face off and
they were standing about a metre apart
and Sanne showed his teeth and I Nina
just backed off and you realize there's
no carcass here and moved away so
hopefully our son is not going to go for
a drink it's beautiful beautiful light
if he does drink from the one side but
no instead he's going to check with I in
his gone he's going to just jump up his
mound make
sure that the coast is clear before he
kind of moves away from the sanctity of
thickets and trees that he could
potentially use to hide away so he's
just watching naina is she kind of
probably strolls off I'm gonna just
reverse a little bit just so I can see
where the aina actually is at the moment
given that he's kind of watching over
his shoulder doesn't look like he seems
to perturb now can you see the hiney
anymore no no now he's lay back down
which is not ideal so he's not going to
go for water like I had hoped now that
this Ines moved off I thought he was
going to head in that direction and
actually go drink but
so 807 years old you make a valid point
Aidan can he not scare away thy Nina
because he's bigger
well Aiden [ __ ] I mean actually it's
drifting off down far far far far from
where we are now and Aidan he could if
he really really wanted to but remember
Aidan that a hyena has got a very very
strong bite and so that means that if it
bites wasana
he's going to get a very sore paw or a
sore leg or maybe even worse it might
break something and then he can't feed
himself and he's not able to actually
then survive and so it's much easier
just to try and leave the heiner's alone
and move away from hyenas and try and
kind of go in a different direction then
it is to try and fight with them and so
that's why he'll rather just kind of
hiss and growl and then move away and it
I you know walk off and hyenas actually
we don't want to fight with leopards
either because they also don't want to
get injured but they will check and make
sure that there's no food in case they
can potentially steal something and you
know maybe get themselves a meal so both
of them have mutual respect they're both
just kind of looking around and
investigating and once thing is happy
that there's no future just moves off
and leaves the lippert alone and the
nipper doesn't have to try and fight
today you know because otherwise it
might get very badly hurt and because
they don't live in families no one will
look after them if they do get hurt
hello boy isn't he beautiful that is as
good as you can ask for from a leopard
up on a man with his little tail kind of
perched up on the mound as well but of
golden light glinting in the eyes
absolutely beautiful
alright so now while husana gazes into
the sunset watching hyena disappear
I believe Steve is much like asana is
sitting and watching one of the most
epic sunsets that we get and that's up
in East Africa in the Maasai Mara yes
indeed thank you the last rays of the
Sun descending behind the mountain their
beautiful pinks oranges and yellows
these zebras are quite enjoying watching
the sunset with a beautiful silhouette
it's a gorgeous picture
I'll file of zebra on the way from the
Riverside back into this open area
probably for the night calling quite a
lot before trying to get themselves all
to maybe move into this team area safety
we've moved from the hyena den to try
capture this sunset and hoping we might
catch some lions moving through after
some of the herds it is that time of day
which nice and cool
perfect time for a hunting cat to be
moving around
Christon this is the time of day lions
normally get active and it normally
starts off with just a little bit of
play and grooming as luck would have it
we bumps into the paradise price just as
they're starting to get active
affectionate play from the youngsters
led as always to some necessary grooming
from month one by one and the pride got
ready to move with more adults join in
the pride from the shelter of the
thickets where they know - escape the
heat of the day the young zebra lots ki
hungry took on the task of selecting
dinner the lionesses set back and
watched dividing hunters at work with
denote steak and darkness soon upon them
it was clear that the Cubs had store
many lessons to learn before they could
be regarded as important members of the
prides hunting elite
Oh interesting was it watching those
Cubs move around they were definitely
hungry definitely had some eyes on some
zebra in the distance but the topi were
watching them the whole time and
eventually after not even an attempt
just basically moving in the direction
they realized that the adults were
moving in another way and they thought
well if we want food we better follow
suit there's dust
I might sneeze that's it's borderline
sorry I think it's gone there they are
busy feeding heads are down and there's
a dangerous time of day for a zebra
lions lurking in the long grass they're
moving through from a distant area they
don't know what has been lying up and
waiting here
they could be Lions lying up in ambush
that's why they normally move in a
single-file sort of line or as a point
man as you know the group joining in
from the right there yes I'm zebra
shouting in the distance there's a
communication call often also an alarm
call so far I haven't yet found a
predator with zebras up here making that
noise more just to come on everybody
let's come hang out together kind of
cool beautiful colors you see how
individual there's rubbing the other one
with its head they're very touchy-feely
very tactile animals okay so we are
going to move on from our stripes see if
we can find something Tony but back to
Tristan and his spots hopefully you find
what you are looking for and as you can
see husana is posing as best as we could
ever ever asked him and you think that's
good English but anyway sometimes words
fail us and we just hack through it and
say stings and hope for the best
but he's kind of posing up on this man
and he's giving us this play from his
mound you are looking very good boy
a solid piece of lipid these days those
shoulders and head and look big yawn now
which i think is going to be an
indication that he's going to start
moving and maybe it's time to go and
have a drink are you thirsty boy seems
like he might be a little bit thirsty
and that's why he wants to kind of
hidden off and maybe try and go to get a
go pan the problem that he's going to
have is that actually there is another
visitor at Gallagher pan at the moment
that we can't see right now but we'll
try and kind of maybe see if wasana
heads there for sauna does go there
we'll be able to kind of see what I was
talking about but essentially there was
an elephant bull that walked right
behind where Hasani is now and towards
Galago pan so we'll see if he kind of
heads there maybe he will and we'll be
able to kind of get a view of him and
the illegal in the background so Farley
hasn't come around the mound yet it came
from the right side and was going to the
left but I think it's after pan drinking
as soon as there's a bit of water
splashing I would imagine husana might
actually start thinking about kind of
looking over the mound to investigate
what's going on behind him but we've had
Mehsana inna now husana and elephants
around and so everything seems to just
be coming through the prints which is
supposed his magnetic little personality
getting everyone coming here yes James
Richard you're exactly right handsome
husana contemplating food or life who
knows it's tricky to say with him
because he's you know constantly got
food on the brain he typically looks for
food all the time and so I wouldn't be
surprised if he is trying to kind of
think about where his next meal is going
to come from and what potentially is
around maybe there's something that's
actually in this area that he's
potentially interested in and that's why
he's kind of looking around maybe he
spotted something I don't think so
though those yawns do indicate that he
should start thinking about actually
moving at some point so I'm hoping that
he's gonna get up off his bound and go
and have a drink it's just such a
beautiful afternoon that it'll be quite
nice
so far Yazzie tough to say I mean
there's a lot of time still to go and
lots of things still to happen if he is
going to take over ting Ghana's
territory but essentially it might
happen they might very well be kind of
that's happening and I hope that it is
because I would be really really happy
if he did end up taking over this
territory but it would be great for us
I'm going to see that there's an LED
Mehsana nobody's catching you a break
I'm afraid my boy everybody's taking
your pen just really wants to go and
drink everybody else is around I would
love to be able to show you the ad but
it's gonna be able tricky because
there's no way to get forward yes are
you now going to give up on drinking boy
I'm sorry right let's get back and try
and figure it out right I'm gonna just
quickly try and reverse and try and get
with Hasani again but while I do I was
saying that it's been a tough week for
husana with losing kills but it's been
an even tougher week for Pearl and for
kasi
we returned to him for cars he's killed
the next morning but we arrived to find
a different face on the scene as usual
members of the Juma clan are in
attendance Singhania however had stopped
feeding something had clearly caught his
attention started around and all of a
sudden descended the tree with the
complete disregard for his safety
hyena gave a short chase but were more
interested in the dangling carcass and
left the Juke to groom himself in the
warm spring Sun in Ghana after a few
glances it's autumn mighty saw as he
stamped his authority as ruler over them
clean and well-fed the Duke then
wandered down to the nearest water to
quench his thirst before finding some
shade to settle in for the day well you
can see this any bull is about to move
off but we're hoping for kasi to kill
stolen by the Duke in the space of about
four days ting Ghana has a absolute
knack for finding food how he does it I
don't know he must have the strongest
sense of smell out of any leopard ever
because he always seems to find kills
that are around but beggars are le bull
walking off into the golden light so
it's when I catch up with the sauna
before he kind of disappears so you'll
see the ileal jurors kind of move
through those golden rays isn't that
beautiful that's very very very pretty
with dust in the air as well as there
any kind of strolls off how wonderful
magical scene isn't that is kind of
typical of Africa right now while the
illy walks into the Rays of the Sun set
I believe telly mccurdy is driving into
the sunset
let's send you back across to her
I think it's probably my favorite time
of the day when I get to drive into the
sunset it's lovely
so our elephants left us they carried on
with their journey of searching for
water and delicious grass to eat which
they won't find at this time of the year
but good luck to them anyways maybe they
find themselves underneath the jackal
berry tree and they can munch on some
sugary treats but so after leaving that
lion pounding is still fast asleep I've
been thinking about the Inca boomer
pride a lot and I've been seen their
tracks all around in this area so
there's a possibility we might get a
chance to see them but I did and I have
all I have already spent a couple of
hours with them which proved our to be
quite fun the Inca Houma pride mundane
boys and the Mon Calamari male gave me
the runaround on the sunrise Safari
luckily we were able to find them in the
afternoon they moved around from out of
the shade and into the golden light to
catch the last of the afternoon warmth
they then snoozed until the Sun set
behind the horizon and rather large herd
of buffalo was just in the distance and
the Lions eventually got to their feet
followed their noses in the direction of
the large birds all right it was so
lovely just been pretty much the entire
afternoon Safari with the Inca home a
pride I did enjoyed even though most of
the time they're just rolling around and
teasing us with signs of waking up
eventually they did get up and then
short trying to follow them through that
crazy crazy thickets man it was hard
through all the Bush willows are all the
silver clasps lychees so we decided to
go back our turn around and we waited on
the fire break and eventually we got to
see them one last time which was nice
now I don't know whereabouts they are on
shatrah I couldn't get hold of anybody
to actually find out if they were even
there to begin with so we're just sort
of bumbling around we're heading to that
waste and sector of the reserve again
where we had seen and the wild dogs just
a couple of days ago actually two days
ago in fact so
the vermin I don't know when they were
last spotted I think they must have been
seen yesterday morning all this morning
but they not on Juma just yet but this
is a great time for them to do one last
run around try and find something to eat
so we might as well be on the move as
well because if you are stuck on one
place and you haven't got anything the
chances of something coming towards you
is quite slim so I think we'll head
towards the most western boundary and I
suppose from that side we'll also get a
really incredible sunset so it's you
know I suppose it's not bad thinking to
go down that way it will just keep on
keeping on now of course East Africa is
about an hour ahead of us so the Sun has
sit behind the Oh lalala escarpment
event Steve is about to get a spotlight
arts and ready for the nocturnal
creatures almost
field training movement of the Tauri
nature on our way along this road
anything could pop out yeah the
marvelous way of the wilderness this
vast open areas these are prides of
moving with the herds killing as they go
the other day we didn't see it but one
lioness with the male killed three for
the best just because they were there
it's their killing frenzy that happens
this time here they definitely are doing
a lot so hoping to just get one of those
happening at some stage the temperature
being a lot cooler now the wind is
slightly picked up good opportunity for
it for it okay well yes it is an odd
spectrum spean I wish I could see like
that make things a lot easier it's often
when it's dark and be looking at the
screen you can really see what's going
on misty that's why we use the
spotlights these planes are vast and
very very wide
they're in smaller groups watching we
are indeed we're following him as he's
kind of moving away he's decided too
much competition of that ought to point
so he's now going to go for a stroll
north of the pan he likes to walk around
this area hopefully he's not gonna drag
us through too many thickets it'll be
nice if he just kind of uses the
pathways that are in the section I meant
st. marking as he goes stopping pausing
listening looking trying to kind of see
if he can find any sign of probably of
another meal there he goes again seems
like he might have spotted something
look at that curl in the tail isn't that
just so lipid like it's so cool when
they do that this is a beautiful animal
I don't really find how people can't
find a lipid beautiful it's an amazing
creature to watch walking through me so
fortunate that we get to watch this all
the time
right now we've seen Hassan ascend
barking we've seen him moving around
what that's goats in Ghana quite wet
either way it's in Ghana this earlier
this week dip he caught the scent of
something
after a week of successful feeding was
time for the Duke to do his territorial
patrol he sniffed and Fleming grimaced
clearly catching the scent of another
ting Ghana deciding the scent could not
be left promptly lifted his tail and
sprayed his own signature on the tree
the sense of another had clearly sparked
him into action as he spent the majority
of his afternoon patrolling the only
briefly stopped at bushes and termite
mounds to lay down his scent satisfied
he had laid down a clear chemical trail
he even lets out his telltale saw to
reaffirm to all who is still the duke of
humor
well hopefully that's a good sign that
Singhania is just kind of reaffirming
his boundaries and it seems like he's
not worried about husana he's not
tracking lisanna Donnie was actually
moving away from where husana was when
he was st. marking like that so it seems
like he's not too sort of concerned with
Hasan is marking but more of maybe
others now Mehsana is busy moving
through a very tricky area it's going to
be a bit of a struggle to follow him as
he goes through me probably going to get
a bit of signal breakup so before that
happens I'm going to send you back
across to Taylor as our little boy it
wanders through the thickets in still
into the sunset I'll be doing that all
day every day
well not quite every day but would you
like to have a look at it what I'm
driving into I bet you would so peaceful
and beautiful there the Drakensberg
mountains a beautiful Sun and the
silhouetted trees and the graceful
sounds of crown lapwings
isn't that gorgeous the northern sabi
sand is very very like here there
definitely aren't very many views like
this down on the south the fact that we
get to look back at this incredible
backdrop even though it feels like it's
just a stone throw away it's a good
hour-and-a-half two-hour drive to get to
those mountains if it's I'm sorry that
you must be regular safaris but yes like
you said the Sunday Safari lives is
definitely a fantastic update of
everything that has gone on so if you
can't make it and join us on the sunrise
and sunset safaris just remember make
time for a Sunday and you'll be filled
in on all the happenings that have
happened the happenings that have
happened
well if we go off we go okay we're down
in the waist now obviously it's like
we're aging closer to the Sun so we'll
just scratch her on here for a little
bit and see what wonderful creatures and
decide to show themselves to us we're
definitely gonna have to add some
jerseys on soon it's getting a little
bit chilly
and this Vichy that the wind is slowly
starting to pick up and the groomer
might be in for a windy evening I'm
happy it said but if I'm wrong there I
hope it's not too windy just a gentle
breeze just to keep things nice and cool
right now
Tristan obviously was battling through a
dangerous spot he's managed to navigate
through it and now husana is on the
prowl
he is indeed so where he's walking right
now a Tai Chi just bolted off so he
seems to be on the probably can see look
I stopping and looking now trying to
work out where did this dykey go so he
can work on hearts okay to his next meal
so even though he's got a full tummy
back on the prowl once again looking for
food so we're gonna try and keep up with
him hitting pretty much towards an old
high end intense eyes that's just north
of us yet so it's nice is kind of track
that goes this way which is delightfully
helpful because if he had gone across
the next drainage down to our right it
would have been a lot more tricky to
have followed the little prince' around
and so I'm quite glad he decided to use
this route more than anything else
so I want to go charging forward too
much because I'm not sure where that
dico ran off to it seems to be kind of
moving through there
all right well Steve in terms of how
holding on will react we don't know this
is a new thing that tingle Hassan is
doing
so whether ting gana gets irritated by
it and tries to chase wasana out I'm not
sure or you might just kind of be like
well it's my son I know who it is not
too stressed about it he's not
competition at this stage and he's still
too small for me I don't know it's gonna
be interesting in certainly a bold move
from husana and a change in his behavior
the first time this week that I've
actually seen him scent-marking scraping
his feet we've been seeing him lifting
his tail and spraying from time to time
over the past few months but nothing
along the lines of actually scraping his
back legs now it looks like he's
actually stalking something so I'm gonna
just try and get into a nice little
position here and then turn off and
we'll just try and see what he's up to
there we go I don't want to drive too
much and clutter into too many stumps
because of the way that he is kind of
moving you see him here
just on the right that is a poised cat
that is definitely focused and seen look
at the heart he's kind of going for a
little bit and then just watching and
looking and just trying to see what's
going on no obviously whatever it was
has moved off too far from him I thought
it wasn't must have been closer than
that the way that he initially started
stalking he's also got his tail up now
which generally is an indication that is
no longer hunting so we're gonna try and
kind of keep up with him as he goes
maybe his potentially could be stalking
us what dwarf mongooses right off just
not as well could potentially be
stalking Matt yes that's exactly what
he's stalking there's a dwarf mongooses
that just ran into this pile of thickets
and he's kind of on our left side I mean
right side coming across in the the
lifts it was a Walter dwarf mongoose ran
from there to the left so that's what
he's actually watching at the moment not
really a good meal I think this is more
just him kind of going after
something that moves more than it's
actually him looking for food at dwarf
mongooses not something that they really
eat they often kill them very seldom do
they actually eat them which is quite
interesting and it takes a bit of skill
to catch a dwarf Mongoose the dwarf
Mongoose is not an animal that moves
very slowly and is quite keen eyesight
and at this time of the day will not be
far from its little den and will
probably disappear quite quickly nope
decided Wharf Mongoose is not on the
menu
so off he goes let's keep up with him as
he does are you going to come back onto
the path for us hasana no I think he's
going to head towards the big termite
mound
Chantell you and me both when they
twitch that tail it's the best thing
ever I also love it when they do it's
kind of like you can see that there's
the little hamster inside the brain is
kind of running at full speed when they
touch the tail hello boy what's he doing
no it's just on a typical kind of
mission that he likes to walk see a
little julep is starting now
well it's not just starting it's
actually getting quite big now it's
really starting to get his dad's kind of
looking that he's going to get a nice
big julep at some point and straight
towards where that mound is that's a man
that he often kind of comes to it's an
old hyena den that used to be in this
area it's not active with the current
hyenas we've checked it around here and
there's no sign of Thein is moving in
this area but it gives you an idea of
kind of where he is at the moment still
walking north I suspect he's going to
puff up he's going to probably go to
tambuti damn it's an area that he has
been going to every now and then and
then maybe run towards buffers of damn
side so I wouldn't be surprised that we
see him in that area he might also kind
of head up there and then decide to come
back south and head back towards the dam
cam that could also be quite possible
right still moving off quite quickly so
let's try and catch up with him if he
gets too far away
problem is if he decides to move off of
this road or to track we're going to be
in lots of trouble we will not be able
to keep up with him at all he'll be
going into thickets that really just are
not easy but he spotted something what's
that in the distance there Seb is that
niala or something straight spot over
his head basically to the right yes
there's an Yala this is not going to
bode well fast I'm afraid because what
he's going to do is he's not going to
walk up this path to go to those niala
he's going to get himself into the
thickest bush possible so that he can
camouflage and that means there you go
you see he's heading straight off
towards the thickets where he's going to
try and hunt them but look at that see
he's got his head down he is focused
forward
isn't that cool I don't know if we're
gonna be able to keep up with him but we
definitely going to sit way way way back
and to see what is going to happen
Maxine you say this is really exciting
it feels like you here in person well
Maxine I'm glad that you are excited and
that you are enjoying this it really is
something special to follow and lip it
as it goes on a hunt you can see the
niala in the distance I'm not going to
move any further I'm going to give lots
and lots of space from here we can see
the liquid moving nicely towards those
niala so for now we don't need to move
at all and it's a very special thing
that we get an insight into these
spotted cats live and you can see he
stops now and he's just looking so I
think you know what he's trying to work
out is exactly what he's going to do
he's got a very long way still to go
it's probably about a hundred meters
that he's got a cover still to get to
those niala so it's a long long long way
unfortunately camera leans kind of
compresses the image so it looks like
there's new al are much closer than they
really are but he's got a lot of work to
do if he's going to get anywhere near
those niala just yet and the Nala
walking the wrong way for us to I was
hoping they were going to drift towards
us and away from that thicket but they
were walking straight into it which is
good for him but very bad for us at this
stage because we are going to
unfortunately probably not be able to
follow him if he does hunt inside that
thicket also we probably just disturb
his hunting if we did because of the
amount of trees that we'd have to hit
and
ashin kind of knocked over so if he
moves forward mm-hm
y'all have all gone into their thickets
and he's just watching this so I think
what he did is just wait now for the
NYADA to move into the thicket and then
Hills probably start going that way
there we go now the last ones gone in
he's going to move in there as well so
I'm gonna trying to see if we can get
into a good position to view him and the
niala while I do that though let's send
you all the way back up to Steve he's
still on the search for those turning
cats and well hopefully as night 2 sins
he will be able to find one of them
somewhere in that area catch yourself
some dinner we've bumped into another
you know whether they are related to the
North can not is very hard to say a
whole bunch of them living in one of the
little holes and the culverts of the
road they're on both sides of this road
yeah we were hoping to catch up with
some tawny cats but we'll do it could be
an offshoot of the North Klan I mean
apparently there's up to 60 70 members
in the Klan that size so this is
probably just another little a den site
if it is the same plan it starts to get
active a little bit of greeting ceremony
happening there with the youngster see
the submissive behavior there in the
background very submissive lying on its
back yeah wind and the light the perfect
time to start getting active see the one
on the right tail is up and it's a
little bit of a sort of excitement in
the air I'm not sure whether the
laughing in all she looks like she's got
blind in the one eye did you see how
that coloration was different I mean
they definitely do cackle you know and
when they are being submissive to each
other the the lower ranking ones
definitely will cackle more but when
they're in a conflict situation with and
the hyena they all cackle they will make
an enormous amount of noise
any of that's got to do with social
standing that's got to do with sort of
the collection of the group keep them
all together as they move in as one to
dominate another group you can clearly
see is not shining back which indicates
it's probably damaged and she seems
perfectly fine I've seen lots of animals
with injured eyes it seems to just get
on with business and the moment of
getting busy is slowly getting relaxed
again I'm sure they'll be getting up
early evening nice wind in the air no
doubt they are probably hungry
well maybe not there's so much food
available and probably eating more than
their they share every single day still
can't help themselves they've got
borders to patrol territories to uphold
and they've got a walk off their meals
they'll get nice and fat around tomorrow
these days sausages these seven members
yep the wind you can tell by the
movement of the grasses is quite strong
you probably hear it on my mic as well
and well I leopard will kill hyena Cubs
and eat them if they can get them same
as eating wild cups pups if they can get
hold of them the opposite is true as
well all predators would have
essentially killed their competitions
youngsters if they can get hold of them
hyena pups are more successful in that
they are able to meet while their period
themselves they go into the ground and
they've got their safety offered in
safety of a hole so they're a lot more a
lot more sort of protected than little
pine and leopard cubs successful in the
rearing
there's an offensive lion cubs that's
why I have to move them quite regularly
find em under a bush is not the best way
to keep them but that is where it works
these landscapes population does quite
well even with that with a quite poor
success rate probably only one one cub
in elitsa will make it to adulthood an
average very good success rate if you
ask me every now and again it'll be
better on the pride and the competition
within the area of course okay to flop
right down and scratch its face and it's
what you do in the morning but is there
morning you see it's time for them to
wake up and start getting active you
know nights like this well on our way
here we started seeing of all the busy
roads are really banning up together
it's very windy very hard to feel safe
in an environment where this constantly
predators lurking when you can't hear
the wind is swarthy so the smell as well
is quite sort of all over the place use
it to their advantage okay
are we going to move offer from these
hyena and then let's go back down to
Taylor mccurdy in South Africa so our
search for the wild dogs has been
unsuccessful sadly but that is just one
of those things we did have an
incredible afternoon Safari though
filled with a sleeping lion and
elephants and I suppose all the antelope
and the sabi sand don't you think we saw
enough in Jana and all sorts of other
creatures today so that has been very
much entertaining but who knows what
also happened a little bit later and all
the sounds that you're here on the dam
can so make sure you keep listening out
for that but for the final minutes of
the show I'm sure you'd like to spend it
with Tristan and of
the young chief well it's a very very
long distance view of husana
down in the thickets because we are not
moving anywhere near him he's still
hunting and still trying to get closer
to those in our land if we go anywhere
near him all we going to do is just
scare off his potential meals and so
what are we doing because we're just
allowing him to really kind of have a
bit of a chance to kind of take it easy
into hunt and hopefully he will be able
to try and find some sort of semblance
of food during the night we'll come
check up here tomorrow but I hope that
you all had an absolutely wonderful time
with us this evening it's been a blast
we've had lots and lots of interesting
things in a another great week of
catching up with all of our favorite
animals that we see out here in both the
Mara and Juma so from all of us has been
an absolute pleasure hope like I say
that you enjoyed it and we'll see you
all next week same time same place for
another edition of safari lives